all right in
philadelphia we've assumed that carson
wentz is going to be good to go it's not
like he's recovering from a torn acl he
had that back issue that knocked him out
in december
but
peterson doug peterson the head coach of
the eagles said at a press conference
that carson wentz has been on the field
during workouts in the current phase of
the offseason program phase two but he
said he's not going to get specific
about the quarterback's workload at this
point here here's peterson explaining
the status of carson wentz specifically
as it relates to when we're going to see
him yeah in otas here's peterson
he's been working
encouraged by his progress and where
he's at and
and uh just looking forward to uh
you know the next few weeks with him
when otas start in less than two weeks
we'll be on the field how does that
pertain to rookie mini camp
it's all about carson right
now it's about the rookies that are in
this weekend
so you won't say if he's gonna be on the
field not right now not until we get to
that point
he's on the field right now in phase two
so yeah
but it's a different type of practice
different type of workout than otas yeah
we'll address it when we get to ota
i i love doug peterson and i i feel like
sometimes these coaches think that they
can hide behind that well i'm i'm here
meeting with you to talk about this like
the draft we're only here to talk about
the draft and and then the reporter will
try to take a question and cram it into
something about that
look if you're available to the media
you got to be ready for anything that's
right and uh starting quarterback your
team is carson wentz said i don't care
if it's rookie mini camp or veteran camp
or whatever the hell it is you're
allowed to ask the quarterback when the
coach is available to the media so when
he answers the question the way he did
yeah do you think he's being cute or do
you think he's got something to hide no
i think he's not sure where where the
status of carson wentz is yeah and his
ability to uh
you know be a part of ota so i don't
think he wants to make a commitment yet
you know i i'm gonna try to figure this
out and make a few phone calls because
it was kind of news to me i thought oh
okay well carson sounds like
everything's good um so i don't have any
definitive answers here yet but with
those type of answers yeah that makes me
believe that there's something that's
not quite a hundred percent yet to where
maybe they do want to you know
maintain him or or mess with his
schedule a little bit so he doesn't wear
his back out i just i am astounded by
the presumption
that wence is going to be fine he's
going to play like he did in 2017 before
he tore his acl he's going to stay
healthy all year right and they're going
to be right in the thick of things for
the super bowl i mean i'm not saying it
won't happen yeah but the idea that it's
guaranteed to happen we've seen the last
two years we know the trend now the
trend is he gets injured in december
something on him breaks he wears down he
puts himself in a bad spot and until i
see tangible evidence of carson wentz
changing his playing style yeah that
possibility is still going to loom for
him just like it does for other you know
cam newton said friday sure i'm too old
to change right well you're going to be
too old to play soon too if you don't
change no i mean so all we talked about
with andrew luck the last three or four
years until he had a year like this year
where he played the entire season and
then now we quiet and shut up and we
don't talk about it that's what carson
wants is gonna have to do you know hey
two years ago he was young he was stupid
he dove into the end zone and took an
unnecessary shot against the rams in the
end zone end of the season tear your acl
you're done the next year and when he's
playing you know last year i think it
was more of a cumulative effect i mean
when he was playing man he was getting
hit a lot they were beat up as a
football team you know people forget
that aspect of it they kind of got
healthy when nick foles came in but yeah
him adjusting his style of play is going
to be paramount i think for him and the
future of the eagles and everything
about it you know to have that clock
what we talk about like russell wilson
just knowing a split second when to get
down when to get out of harm's way
carson wentz does not have that and how
to take that how to position your body
instinctively i'm not worried about it
but think about this you're going to be
ready to go you mentioned the cumulative
effect last year and and think about how
easy he had it because he was rehabbing
his acl he didn't play in a few games he
didn't play in the pre-season yeah so
the wear and tear wasn't the same as it
would be in a normal i mean maybe this
is just they're trying to manage him so
there isn't a cumulative effect but i i
just look i know it's not a popular take
for the folks in philadelphia if i was
an eagles fan i would be scared to death
that this is going to be our reality
every year instead of having a franchise
quarterback who can show up every day
and play at a high level every every
sunday and he's going to be there and we
know he's going to stay healthy and it's
a given right
it's not going to be a given and every
year it's going to be this all right
when is the morning that we find out
that carson wentz is done for the year
yeah and you're going to worry about
that until you get two or three straight
years of nothing
that happens yeah you're going to worry
about that if you're not
it's it's something to worry about i'm
not stressed about it though i think he
can you're not an eagles fan no if
you're an eagles
that's my point you like the giants
you're happy about it no i'm not happy
about it i like carson wentz take a
break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports